So we talked about Republican Senator Mitch
McConnell ending the overt farce that the
last five weeks have been and congratulating
Joe Biden as president elect since.
After all, Joe Biden did win the election.
Now we immediately have the blowback to this
story, which is that almost instantly Donald
Trump himself and Trump, including Kuhnen
conspiracy theorists and others, immediately
turned on Mitch McConnell fomenting the Republican
civil war.
We discussed earlier in the week.
Earlier this week, I did a segment called
Republican Civil War MAGGA protesters chant
Destroy the Republican Party.
And that story generated quite a bit of interest.
And in that segment, I said, whether there
is reconciliation within the Republican Party
as Joe Biden becomes president will depend
on Trump and what Trump does.
Now, we have to sort of primary scenarios.
If Trump just shuts up and disappears to play
golf or do whatever, the Republican Party
will come back together.
The wackiest elements like Kuhnen will evaporate.
And you'll get back to the pre Trump Republican
Party.
On the other hand, if Donald Trump and his
most ardent cultists keep going, you may have
a protracted Republican civil war.
And if it goes on for a few more weeks, it
might actually hurt Republicans in the Georgia
Senate runoff, which would be great.
And it's looking more and more like at least
in the next month.
That second scenario is the most likely scenario.
Very late last night or early this morning,
I think just after midnight Eastern Time,
Donald Trump took to Twitter in response to
Mitch McConnell congratulating Joe Biden and
acknowledging that Joe Biden won and is the
president elect.
Trump tweeted and quoted from an article and
said, Mitch.
Seventy five million votes, a record for a
sitting president by a lot too soon to give
up Republican Party must finally learn to
fight.
People are angry and indeed, right on cue,
the Kuhnen conspiracy theorists.
Q And on being this pro Trump conspiracy ideology
listed as a domestic terror threat by the
FBI, Kuhnen conspiracy theorists immediately
started accusing Mitch McConnell of working
for the deep state of being a RINO, a Republican
in name only, which is pretty funny, which,
since he's the Senate majority leader, many
kuhnen cultist accounts on social media said
they would be leaving the Republican Party
because Mitch McConnell acknowledged an empirical
reality that Joe Biden won the election.
And the messages from the Kuhnen people ranged
from You're a disgrace.
Mitch McConnell to today marks the birth of
the America first party to congratulations
bitch.
McConnell today marked the death knell of
the Republican Party because of your treasonous
actions, telling party members not to back
Trump.
So a few thoughts on this, all relevant to
the next two to four years of American politics.
First, Trump mad at Mitch McConnell, Kuhnen
mad at Mitch McConnell.
Trump mad at the Georgia Governor, Brian Kemp.
This is a dream for Democrats trying to win
these two Senate seats and take control of
the Senate for the next two years.
We've said the polling is close in Georgia
and it's really a tossup.
I mean, we've got margins of one to two in
the polls that we're seeing for both Democratic
challengers John OSF and Raphael Warnock.
You really can't dream up a better scenario
in a red state where Democrats are trying
to win, then some Republicans thinking it's
rigged against them and maybe staying home,
boycotting the election while others are threatening
to leave the party.
You could not ask for a better scenario as
Democratic challengers trying to take over
seats currently held by Republican incumbents.
So this little kerfuffle has the potential
to hand Senate control to Democrats.
This also thinking more broadly.
This also signals the future about something
we've talked to talked about before.
What happens to Trump is when Trump leaves,
do they simply become regular Republicans
and start talking about lowering taxes and
regulations and paying off the debt?
Because that's not what the Kuhnen types have
been during the Trump cult peak years.
It seems to me that for many of these Kuhnen
and Trump cultists, it's not going to be rewarding
or interesting.
It's going to be too milquetoast to just be
normal Republicans.
And we might see some of them leave politics
altogether, some maybe get involved in something
more radical.
And that's exactly the signal that they're
sending right now.
Now, just a funny side note on the Mitch McConnell
congratulations thing.
Vladimir Putin and Mitch McConnell both congratulated
Joe Biden this week for winning.
Trump only lashed out at Mitch McConnell.
And it's just it's poetically perfect.
And it it continues to be.
But we're getting closer to the end.
And I want to remind you, January one twenty
one, so this is our one one twenty one membership
drive, we want to start the next year off
really powerfully.
So on January 1st, we are doing a one day
membership special.
It will be themed based on the date.
So the special will be related to one one
twenty one.
OK, that's all I'm saying.
If you want to be if you've been thinking,
I kind of like what you do David, but you
know, I don't really like your voice, so I
don't really like the shape of your mouth
as someone wrote to me last week.
But you like the content and you've been thinking
about supporting Get on our newsletter at
David Pakman Dotcom.
And then on January one, you will be notified
perfectly with instructions as to how to take
advantage of this great membership special.
Quick break.
Back after this.